foreign
[Music]
classical music starts playing as I've
been watching you for a very long time
studying you
Percy hmm You're Gonna Be Right
I don't want to be right you're gonna be
right you're gonna be right interesting
candles [ __ ] and then here you go
so because I know everything about you
Amy yes you smell your taste
born in 1999 in Milwaukee your parents
were a hard-working immigrant family
you worked every day even though they
called you [ __ ] poo poo at school
and covered their noses and said ew
[ __ ] poovoo's eating that poo poo food
the world sees you as homeless but I
know what you really are somebody who
sacrificed everything to get a 911
Memorial built in Brooklyn
foreign
once it was built did you feel complete
no you never will you filled that void
with men
and women
and swimming
and schmen field the only thing that
doesn't have a soul amen that doesn't
have a homes Amy is your soul
and I'd like to provide that for you
please Amy let me house your soul
[Music]
Frozen and I two cameras and we'll make
something better than this in a week
Amy
have you ever tasted human flesh
gamey as you would
especially pulls out a knife
when you make them run
so sharpening the knife Amy do you know
where we get the hair for our Americans
why they're so soft
because they're real they're so cute
oh my God
Americans Amy
why do you think there were no razors in
the bathroom
we wanted you to grow but now it is time
to harvest
American Psycho
foreign
[Music]
all right we're done come on guys
dude